What we're going to do in
this video is think
about two wave sources.
But one of them is going to be
stationary and the other one
is going to be moving.
And just to have a concrete
number, it's moving at 5
meters per second
to the right.
And what we're going to think
about is where are the crests
of the wave that it's
been releasing for
the last 3 or 4 seconds?
So let's say that in both cases,
they are releasing a
wave. So the velocity of the
wave is going to be 10 meters
per second.
You could visualize this, maybe,
as a sound wave, but
sound and air move much, much,
much, much faster than 10
meters per second.
But this'll make the
math work out easy.
Especially relative to this
guy, who is moving to the
right at 5 meters per second.
And that's the whole point, to
give you the intuition and
make the math really
simple here.
And both of these guys are going
to be, the wave that
they're emitting is at
10 meters per second.
And the period of the wave
is going to be at
1 second per cycle.
And if the period is 1 second
per cycle, you take the
inverse of that-- the frequency
of the source, I
guess you could call it, of the
wave, as being emitted is
going to be the inverse
of this.
The inverse of 1 is just 1.
But 1 cycle per second.
If it takes a second for a
cycle, it's also in 1 second,
you're also going to see 1
cycle, so 1 cycle per second.
So let's think about what's
happening here.
So let's think about where--
let's say it emitted a crest
of it's a wave exactly
1 second ago.
Where is that crest
going to be now?
Let's think about the stationary
character.
Well, this guy emitted
a crest 1 second ago.
It's moving outward.
So this is outward.
It's movie outward radially.
We need to give a direction if
I'm giving a vector quantity.
So it's moving outward at
10 meters per second.
So if it emitted it 1 second
ago, it's going to be 10
meters radially outward
from the source.
So maybe that is right
over there.
Well, let me draw it a little
bit neater like that.
So that's where that
crest will be.
Now what about this guy?
Where's the crest that this
guy emitted 1 second ago?
You might want to just draw a
radius 10 meters around this
guy as well.
But he wasn't here
1 second ago.
He was 5 meters to the left.
Remember, he's moving 5 meters
per second to the right.
1 second ago, he was 5
meters to the left.
So maybe that places him
right over there.
So the crest that he emitted 1
second ago isn't going to be
10 meters from this guy.
It's going to be 10
meters radially
outward from that guy.
So this is where he is now.
That's where he was 1 second
ago, where he emitted this
crest that has now traveled
10 meters away.
This a little inexact,
so I could draw it a
little bit like that.
This is 5 meters.
That's 10 meters away.
But you get the general idea.
Now let's keep going.
Let's think about the crest
that both of these guys
emitted 2 seconds ago.
This guy's been stationary
the whole time.
If he emitted it 2 seconds
ago, it's traveling at 10
meters per second.
It's going to be 20 meters
radially outward from the
center, from the source.
So it will look something
like that.
I'm just drawing the
crest of the waves.
If you think of water, a pebble
being dropped into the
pond, these are just the high
points on the wave that
spreads radially outward from
where the pebble was dropped.
Now this guy, once again, you
can't just draw a circle
around this because he wasn't
here 2 seconds ago.
He was right here.
He was right here
2 seconds ago.
1 second ago, he was 5
meters to the left.
A second before that, he was
5 meters more to the left.
So that wave that he emitted
then is going to be 20 meters
radially outward from
this point.
So the center isn't going
to be that or that.
It's going to be that point
where he was 2 seconds ago.
So what about the crest that
either of these of sources
emitted 3 seconds ago?
Well, it would be 30 meters
radially outward, so another
10 meters from the last one.
So it will be out here.
It will be out there
just like that.
This guy has been stationary
the whole time.
But what about this guy?
He wasn't here 3 seconds ago.
He was here.
Right?
1 second ago, here.
2 seconds ago, there.
3 seconds ago, there.
So we're going to be
30 meters radially
outward from this point.
So once again, I can just copy
and paste this right here.
And it should be centered
around that point.
Now, let's think a little bit
about what the perceived
frequency of this wave would be
for a couple of observers.
So we could put an observer
here, really
anywhere around this guy.
We could put an observer
right here.
And then we could put another
observer right here.
Now, what's this guy
going to perceive?
Well, every second he's getting
a pulse-- well,
there's a couple of things
to think about.
First of all, what is the
wavelength of, at least this
wave right here.
Well, every second, he's
emitting a pulse.
So, a second ago, the pulses
out there would
have traveled 10 meters.
And then he emits
another pulse.
So the pulses are going to be 1
second apart, but since they
traveled 10 meters in that 1
second, they are also going to
be 10 meters apart.
So the wavelength,
in this case, is
going to be 10 meters.
The distance between these
crests are 10 meters.
Now what about this situation
right here?
It depends on what side, whether
the source is coming
towards you or whether it's
going away from you.
That's the situation
with this guy.
When it's moving towards you,
it's emitting a pulse-- so
let's say it emitted a pulse
right here-- and then, it
moves 5 meters to
the right before
emitting the next pulse.
So instead of them being 10
meters apart, in this case,
this guy has closed
the distance by
5 meters over here.
So these pulses are only going
to be 5 meters apart.
So over here, the wavelength
is only 5 meters.
You can see it visually.
This distance right here is
half of this distance.
These are 5 meters apart.
And on the left-hand side, if
you're on the side of the
source that the source is moving
away from, it would be
10 meters, but every second the
source is also moving 5
more meters away from you.
So this perceived wavelength
right here is
going to be 15 meters.
And we can see it visually.
That's the whole reason why
I drew it this way.
Now what's going to
be the perceived
frequencies for this?
Well, this guy has one crest
passing him right now.
It's going to take exactly 1
second for the next crest to
get to him because
it's traveling at
10 meters per second.
So he is going to perceive 1
crest, or 1 cycle per second,
or a frequency of 1 hertz,
which makes sense.
This is stationary.
They're both stationary relative
to each other.
And we're also talking about
classical physics.
We're not getting to relativity
and all that.
But the observed frequency is
the exact frequency that was
emitted by this guy
right there.
Now what about this situation?
Each of these crests are 5
meters apart for this guy.
If you imagined that this was
some type of a train coming
towards this guy, each of these
crests are only 5 meters
apart, but they're traveling
at 10 meters per second.
So how many crests are you
going to see in a second?
Well, you're going to
see two of them.
This one's going to take 1/2 a
second to return you, and then
in the next 1/2 a second, this
one's going to get to you.
Or you could say this one takes
1/2 second to reach you,
and this is going to take
1 second to reach you.
So you're going to see two.
So there's two ways
to think of it.
You could say your period in
this situation is 1/2 of a
second per cycle.
Or you could invert it and you
could say that the frequency--
I mean we could put the observed
frequency-- is going
to be 2 cycles per second.
And already notice, this guy's
experiencing a higher
frequency then this guy over
here, because these wave
fronts or these crests are
just passing by him more
frequently.
Because this guy is moving in
the same direction as this
guy, they are closer together.
Now this guy's going to
experience the opposite thing.
Let's say that this crest
is just passing him by.
How long will it take for
the next crest to
cover that 15 meters?
Well, they're going at
10 meters per second.
It's going to be 1.5 seconds per
crest. That's going to be
the observed period
for this guy.
You have to take the inverse of
that-- that's 1.5 is 3/2,
that's 2/3 of a --or you could
say crest or 2/3 of a cycle
per second.
So when the source is moving
away from this observer, the
frequency, or the perceived
frequency, is the lower than
the frequency of the actual
emitted wave. When the source
is moving towards the
observer, the
frequency is higher.
This might seem some like some
type of bizarre thing but
you've experienced it before.
It's called the Doppler
effect, which you've
probably heard of.
And that's exactly what you
experience when you sit at,
maybe, a train crossing.
Be careful not to
sit too close.
And as a train is approaching
you, you noticed-- say it has
its horn going on.
It'd be very high-pitched.
And then right when it passes
you, and it starts moving away
from you, it has a
much lower pitch.
And that perceived pitch, that's
your brain and your
ears' way of sensing
frequency.
So when the train is coming
toward you, it's a high pitch,
high frequency.
When it's going away from you,
low pitch, low frequency.
And hopefully, drawing it out
this way gives you a visual
understanding of why that is;
why these points on the cycle,
or these crests, are closer
together when it's moving in
your direction then when they're
farther apart-- when
it's moving away from you.
In the next video, we'll do
these with more abstract
numbers so we can actually
figure out generalized
formulas for relating the
observed frequency with the
emitted frequency.